oh hey what's up welcome to the point
I'm your host Daniel two-wire so earlier
this week konami decided to take PT off
the playstation network meaning that
anyone who didn't already have it
downloaded to their PlayStation 4 won't
be able to access it even if they have
it on their Playstation library so what
does this mean well for Konami it means
that it served its commercial purpose
they're not gonna make silent hill's
so there's no point in having that demo
up there but what about its other uses
what about its other values its value as
an educational tool for designers its
value for the grand scope of video games
culture or video games history this is
nothing new video games disappear all
the time lost cartridges evolving
hardware and defunct companies make
getting access to old games much more
difficult than other mediums like books
musical film you can stream loads of old
music and movies or play DVDs or have a
library collection of your favorite
books but software is tied to constantly
evolving hardware so to play many old
games today we need to copy and emulate
them on modern machines meaning for
decades it's been the role of pirates to
be criminal protectors of our video game
history but we have a new problem online
games games that require servers to run
how do we keep these playable when a
publisher decides they don't want to pay
for the server upkeep anymore
for instance how will gamers 50 years
from now be able to go back and see one
of the most important games of this era
world of warcraft well one way would be
to allow fans and preservation groups to
run private servers but sadly this form
of preservation is illegal without
consent and as a recent scuffle between
the Electronic Frontier Foundation and
the games industry publisher group the
ESA showed publishers aren't interested
in giving consent no matter how long the
games been dead so what are we to do
this is a real crisis for game
preservation with decades-old copyright
laws making it neon impossible to
legally preserve online enabled software
is there any hope for saving this
milestone in gaming's heritage or are we
on the verge of losing thousands of
games forever we're here in Oakland
California to find out we're here to
talk to the good folks at the Museum of
Art in digital entertainment about the
bottle for video game preservation the
point season 3
episode 12 the war on game preservation
[Music]
welcome to the maids the Museum of Arts
and digital entertainment located in a
rather rough-and-tumble part of Oakland
California I've lived in this city for
four months and rarely wander into this
part of town so how surprised I was to
learn that inside this crumbly old
building was a veritable bounty of
gaming history CRT monitors are classics
from throughout the ages a roomful of
hard are waiting to the catalog spectrum
c64 is Amiga 1200 some computers I've
never even heard of let alone played and
on the other side of the hall sits a
classroom where free talks and
programming lessons are given or rather
used to be a classroom a few weeks
earlier classes were suspended when the
roof collapsed there wasn't any class on
but Sally the janitor working here broke
his leg this humble Haven the video game
history is the brainchild of Alex handy
a game's journalist who sort of stumbled
into the world of software preservation
after a chance encounter at a local
market in 2008 I discovered at the Laney
college flea market and Oakland parcel
of about 50 bear chips that contained 12
are visions of Cabbage Patch Kids
adventures in the park for Atari 2600
which had never been released or played
nobody'd ever seen it I dumped all the
roms and made them available most the
more colecovision roms except for the
Atari game made the mall available on
the Internet and realized that the chips
were now historic relics and I wanted to
sort of donate them to someplace they
could preserve them so I looked in the
only organization that really did
preservation video games was the
Rochester the strong Museum of play in
Rochester New York which is rather far
from me here in California in Oakland
and I really felt there needed to be an
institution in the Bay Area that sort of
heralded the artistry of video game
design and development and spread the
gospel of that as it were to sort of
inspire the next generation of game
developers by informing them about the
past so in 2010 I incorporated as a
non-profit and got approved in 2011 we
did a Kickstarter and got $20,000 and in
September 2011 we open the doors here
$20,000 it's not very much no no it
wasn't but the last of this a year it
was only supposed to last six months but
it ended up lasting a whole year and
had free programming classes across the
hall for basically three and a half
years alex is the type of guy I could
happily talk to for hours not only does
he clearly know what he's talking about
when it comes to video games but his
enthusiasm for the work is infectious
and by the sounds of things enthusiasm
is certainly required not only does the
mate provide game preservation and
educational services but it's also a
free museum that's open every weekend
for folks to come in and play hundreds
of classics and not so classics we're
open to the public on weekends from noon
to 6:00 and it's free admission and you
can come in and play the exhibits and we
have a game bar where for $5.00 just
sort of a $5 admission fee to the game
bar you can just point at something on
the shelf
plug it into the plan are there that
many people actually actively involved
in trying to preserve video games you
would be shocked how small the pool is
it tends to be I don't even know if
there's somebody on this continent
charged with doing this for United
States the the Library of Congress has
pallets of video games that it does not
know how to catalogue because some of
them have ISBN numbers some of them
don't it does not have a formal
cataloging system for storing video
games I mean you're asking this question
to a guy who found a game that nobody
had played and was never released
because it was on a piece of black
plastic and silicon about that large and
then put in a room in a box somewhere
for thirty years so our digital assets
easy to preserve are they safe are they
not going away well they aren't if
people get a hold of them and preserve
them it's very sad that the most
significant preservation work up until
the Internet Archive got going was done
by pirates yeah so if you need any
software on the Atari ST or for the
Amiga your easiest bet on finding that
piece of software is on pirate disks
that were distributed underground I mean
it's it's wonderful that work was done
but it is appalling that that is how
this stuff was preserved in an illegal
fashion not because that people were
breaking the law but the fact that that
was illegal yeah that the for
preservation purposes even you know if
we as an organization wanted to
undertake a project like storing all of
these pirate disks we would still be
breaking the law
right we can't preserve that because
that stuff was illegally distributed and
disseminated and there's no fair use of
any kind of the DMCA for stuff that has
any kind of IP rights associated with it
anymore it's it's fair use is so
restrictive these days and we just want
to sort of loosen the valve a little so
the world of video game preservation
already has significant roadblocks but a
new modern problem is cause for fresh
concern what about games that have
online components that are no longer
being supported by their publisher
recently the Electronic Frontier
Foundation attempted to secure an
exemption to section 1201 of the Digital
Millennium Copyright Act
anti-circumvention provisions to allow
players communities researchers
educators and game museums the legal
protection to legally keep these games
playable after a publisher has decided
to shut down the servers the
Entertainment Software Association or
ESA that's the folks that represent
video game publishers and run the
Electronic Entertainment Expo have not
given their support to this exemption
yeah we were talking about the NBA 2k14
yeah so 2k games doesn't want to pay to
have that server up and they want people
to buy the new version of the game but
the 2014 version Dave they've had to put
it back up online because people are so
angry wouldn't it be a much better
solution if some guy on the internet
spent you know a month of his time
rewriting the server code and allowing
people to play it online just you know
you sort of shunt it off to like this
site where people are playing without
without to Kay's involvement and 2k
doesn't have to pay to run those servers
the fans should have a right to keep
that going and play with it because they
paid for it if they want to spend their
time making it work again that's a lot
of work we saw the same thing when
gamespy shut down when like suddenly
there was this massive swath of games a
lot of the me a games that just did not
have much grass for anymore you wanted
to play battlefield 1942 or about the
Vietnam online anymore you know tough
luck absolutely and the game Ranger is
the the platform that ended up
supporting all that and that's one guy
just like writing and risa porting all
of these games and in a lot of cases he
doesn't have permission to do it and you
know there hasn't been any legal
Prakasham repercussions against him for
that yet but again he's in Australia so
that's a little difficult so what about
that like some people would say that oh
you know this stuff exists in like a
legal gray area where like they're not
they're breaking the law but like no
one's gonna chase after them what do you
say to that as somebody who's you know
obviously spending a lot more time
trying to get this stuff done yeah well
the first time that somebody you know
slaps me with a summons for trying to
preserve software then I'll you know be
screaming a lot louder than I am now
right like I just don't want to get to
that point if a company is not making
any efforts on a piece of IP that's like
a cert that has a server that's an
online component and somebody wants to
go and replace that online component
then that's totally a fair use issue I
mean that's a that's a fair use example
I think because it's somebody taking
it's a fan of the work trying to keep it
alive to preserve its original artistic
integrity
right now the meter running a project to
breathe new life into a game called
habitat an MMO on the commodore 64 they
hope to have it available to play online
via javascript browser plugin sometime
soon but this was a big project to
undertake and one they were only able to
break ground on once they'd secured
assurances by the IP holder that they
wouldn't be sued
these are hoops that even an
organization dedicated to game
preservation took months and years to
jump through and that's just one game
right now there are countless online
enabled games that might easily be lost
to time I'm gonna at the SA support
convincing the Copyright Office that
this exemption is essential to securing
video games cultural heritage is a
massive uphill battle I would say that
the work that we're doing with the e FF
on this effort it seems as though the
ESA doesn't you know they're arguing the
other side obviously they don't want
this exemption their specific argument
is that we couldn't cite any specific
games that we were not able to preserve
because of a lack of online play our
reply was to send them a list of
basically just all the PlayStation 2
games
supported oh and that's like hundreds of
games and I didn't you never know why
you want to see these games preserved
for example we had Zombies Ate My
Neighbors and exhibit here and I really
wish I could remember the guys name I'd
have to look it up but basically a girl
Mather came over he's from the
Skylanders team one of the artists and
he said oh you've got to find the
credits on Zombies Ate My Neighbors one
of the guys as you know all the team is
in there and one of the guys you know
died like about three years ago I was a
brain tumor and so we went through the
code and got to the final area where you
can walk around the LucasArts office and
talk to everybody and we found the guy
who had died it was in there even like
you never know what is going to be
significant in a piece of art or the
culture until far after it you know
society has sort of digested it and
passed it along on its way the maid is a
special place powered by passionate
individuals but places like this I'm
fine groups around the world require
legal protection on the cooperation of
publishers if were to secure the
heritage of videogames as an industry we
need to be thankful that there are
people like Alex around the world were
willing to put in the time and effort to
secure our digital heritage so in my
mind it's up to us the ESA and the
Copyright Office to reward these
individuals with secure legal protection
[Music]
the main thing that I really like about
the maid is the our classes the free
classes that we hosted me being able to
teach kids who have never even seen him
house before how to make a video game
it's like the light goes off on their
head it's amazing you see these kids who
parents like well they have a little
trouble in school and they come in and
they sit down for five minutes they go
oh that's why I learned XY coordinates
in class now you move the cat on the
screen all that makes perfect sense now
how do I make the cat blue how do I make
him shoot basketballs and these kids
they never save their game files as
Steve's game it's always Steve super
awesome amazing Dragon Ball 27 X Y Z
it's it really unleashes their
creativity and I kind of missed that
that creativity that I had when I was a
little kid right and you know I had some
classes on basic when I was a little kid
and then really sparked my interests in
computers and that's what we try to do
here
you know I fully understand that in in a
couple of Saturday morning classes we're
not gonna turn out the greatest program
in the world but hopefully that kid the
light goes on and now the rest of their
life they will find the way to learn
because that's all you need to do in the
kids you know turn the key to make them
interest in they'll they'll figure it
out they will find the information and
devour it especially with the Internet
[Music]